it's that time again there's a new
version of iOS headed to your iPhone and
iPad but after last year's disastrous
iOS game upgrade it's easy to see why
you'd be scared no no no not again
you're gonna break everything and kill
my battery I think they just do this so
I'll buy another phone it's cool way yes
yeah it was bad but this year Apple is
concentrated on making the operating
system far more stable it even gave
users early access to help report bugs
I've been using it on the iPhone 5s
iPhone 6 and various iPads and you know
what it feels a lot like using the old
version the operating system is far from
a giant leap in fact as far as new
features goes it feels like apples
playing catch-up with Android and even
Windows but here are the things that I
think make the upgrade more than worth
it and I'm not just talking about the
middle finger emoji 15 iOS 9.1 admit it
this is the worst part of your day but
good news you have a new best friend
meet low-power mode when you switch it
on it disables many of the more power
hungry system features and turns down
brightness when you get into the 20%
danger zone an iPhone 6 with low-power
mode on will last 40 minutes longer than
one without it plus you can see what
apps are all eating at your battery
swipe to the right and you're at what I
like to call serious screen here is
where Siri predicts the next app you
want to use or the next person you want
to talk to she even suggests nearby
locations you may be looking for
depending on the time of day
well yes Siri it is 6 p.m. and I could
use a martini Siri is still nowhere near
as good as Google now at predicting
things but this screen and this search
box is now my first stop to look for a
contact app or an email
and speaking of search the settings menu
now even has its own search box you see
this little strip of text
well it's arguably the biggest thing
about using iOS 9 on your iPhone when
you get taken out of one app into
another you can easily get back by
tapping this link small perks yes and
Android has had a back button for years
but it saves major time there's also a
pretty new multitasking
you butwhy Apple had to change the
direction of the way you swipe the cards
is completely lost on me all these new
features work on the iPad but the newest
iPads finally get some long-overdue
features like split-screen multitasking
unfortunately you'll need the iPad air 2
to do it
but you can now put two apps
side-by-side on the screen the iPad Mini
2 & 3 and the iPad air support this
little slide overview though the new
keyboard tricks and the
picture-in-picture video viewing are
also really handy look you're gonna get
iOS 9 statistically most people upgrade
I'm just saying you're probably gonna
like it for the time-saving tricks and
for the stability that should help with
avoiding this